[Music]
buses and trains without drivers
artificial intelligence shaping every
moment of our lives
people living on mars if you suddenly
woke up in the year
2041 what kind of
future tech would be available to you
would people
be more unified or more divided
and could you wake up to see the earth
on the brink of destruction
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if you slept for the next 20 years
movies present us with futures full of
flying skateboards and flying cars but
there are many ways our world could
change
new technologies are developing faster
than ever
remember what it was like 20 years ago
you didn't have your smartphone didn't
post pictures on facebook and
could never imagine yourself working
remotely
now think about how life could be
different 20 years from now would it be
a perfect utopia or a dystopic nightmare
well you're about to find out we're
putting you to sleep for two decades
so if you woke up in the 2040s
one thing you could count on would be
whatever smartphone or
computer you had in your pocket would be
pretty outdated
forget about the fact that you just
spent 20 years asleep
what is this weird tech discovery number
one
your shiny smartphone was a technology
of the past
yes sorry computers would be attached to
your body in different ways
you might even have smart contact lenses
that display
everything right in front of your eyes
in the 2040s
virtual reality would be used to explore
nature
and sightsee in a whole new way
including smell
and physical sensation don't get
yourself
lost in your new realities artificial
intelligence would shape
every aspect of your life this would
mean vast
improvements in medical diagnostics
there would be
all sorts of advanced methods for
treating diseases
ai would constantly monitor your body to
keep you healthy
maybe you'd even be able to immortalize
your loved ones in the
form of ai avatars
[Music]
automation would exist in all forms of
transportation
you'd never have to drive your car again
this global automation
would significantly alter the work
environment reducing the need for human
labor
but many people would still be working
remotely across different countries and
time zones
drastic changes in labor markets would
likely lead to
even further inequality in society
and the climate crisis would be worse
in 2021 the world was heading for a
global temperature rise
of more than 3 degrees celsius this
century
hopefully as you wake up 20 years later
brilliant scientific methods would have
solved this
would carbon trapping techniques process
industrial waste and prevent it from
entering the atmosphere
would we have given up all fossil fuels
and be relying entirely on renewable
energy like wind and solar
unfortunately it's hard to tell what
world you'd wake up to
it could be a great showcase of
countries united to help our planet
through tough times
or our generation could destroy the
earth as we know it
but hopefully you'd wake up to find a
healthy
socially and environmentally conscious
planet
or you could wake up to see the first
people colonizing mars or
sending probes to explore different
planets
or planning to colonize another planet
like
proxima b but
that's a story for another
what if